[Music]
a historic high stakes summit between
President Trump and Vladimir Putin
unfolding today in Finland the issue of
Russian election meddling hanging over
the talks but president Trump pushing
back against calls to cancel the
face-to-face meeting our relationship
has never been worse than it is now
however that changed as of about four
hours ago nothing would be easier
politically than to refuse to meet as
president I cannot make decisions on
foreign policy in a futile effort to
appease partisan critics or the media or
Democrats who want to do nothing but
resist and obstruct I would rather take
a political risk in pursuit of peace
than to risk peace in pursuit of
politics President Trump also study in
Washington in the world by dismissing
evidence of Russian interference in the
2016 election my people came to me dan
coates came to me and some others they
said they think it's Russia I have
president putin he just said it's not
Russia I will say this I don't see any
reason why it would be but I really do
want to see the server but I don't think
it can go on without finding out what
happened to the server what happened to
the servers of the Pakistani gentleman
that worked on the DNC where are those
servers I have great confidence in my
intelligence people but I will tell you
that President Putin was extremely
strong and powerful in his denial today
Director of National Intelligence dan
coates released in a statement following
President Trent's comments saying in
part quote we have been clear in our
assessments of Russian meddling in the
2016 election and their ongoing
pervasive efforts to undermine our
democracy and we will continue to
provide unvarnished and objective
intelligence in support of our national
security and president Trump tweeting
from Air Force One today as I said today
and many times before I have great
confidence in my intelligence people
however I also recognize that in order
to build a brighter future we cannot
exclusively focus on the past as the
world's two largest nuclear powers we
must
along Helsinki 2018 is the hashtag so we
have all all the people are here today
we'll just start with you Greg and your
thoughts this presidency is the actual
presidency of hope and change people
keep hoping that he will change this is
what you got and if you keep being
surprised by the fact that he's trying
to build relationships like a Salesman
and it gets very disappointing and
shocking you haven't been paying
attention because this is you have to
look at this presidency with fresh
eyeballs he's trying to leave the past
behind and he's trying to build
relationships knowing that you cannot
trust a lot of these people he could
have talked tougher but it will never be
tough enough for most people because
they they see him as a Salesman but
forget about the talk look at the
actions if you want to strangle you know
Putin's Russia you're a public spat
isn't going to do it what you're gonna
do is you're gonna go after their
financial pipelines and you're gonna
have sanctions and and you're gonna arm
the Ukraine so the idea that this he's
the if he is Russia's I don't know
stooge he might be the worst Russian
stooge ever because he's he's been
tougher on them that Obama has so the
thing is yes could have been tougher
could have been tougher but he would
make he would make anybody happy and
this is who he is he's trying to create
relationships this is no different than
North Korea it may work it may not work
but you just can't keep pulling your
hair out because you're not gonna have
any hair left you're gonna look like
brian Stelter kennedy what do you think
about the undermining though of the
intelligence community who basically
told him and then they put out a
statement saying we can tell him all of
these things and if he chooses not to
believe it or chooses to ignore it
that's up to him no I know the
intelligence community has has gone
through a big perceptual flight lately
and a lot of that has been self-imposed
how the intelligence community the FBI
and the CIA they have all essentially
tarnished their own brands because of
what has happened at the very top levels
I'm not talking about day-to-day agents
who work very hard and truly trying to
objectively investigate but having said
that I still believe them over Vladimir
Putin and I think that's what's most
surprising one thing that I took away
from it was the markets were not
affected you know this is if
it is to be believed some of the
hysteria from the left that this is the
most disgraceful performance a president
has ever given in public you would think
if you're talking about two nuclear
superpowers and the idea that one
president is beholden to a corrupt state
that the markets would show that in in
essence you would have seen the rocket
says she bugged off everything
no we they didn't result that the
tariffs and so when the the trade talk
we try to meet you and Mexico and Canada
that's when you would see you know $200
dips per day but the fact that the
market didn't even hiccup I think it may
be the reason for that or although is
that Russia is pretty much a blip on the
radar when it comes from GDP Texas has a
bigger GDP than Russia like we treat
them like their that's so amazing and
they're really not now I agree
and it's Russia's 1/10 the US economy
but I think our colleagues are being too
kind on the 45th president who went off
the rails in Helsinki
it seems to me totally off the point you
know what is it it's like a idiot savant
that you Hillary Clinton and the email
server I mean he despises and distrusts
Hillary Clinton and the special counsel
more than he does Putin and the and the
the KGB or the GRU you call it now I
hate the fact that the mainstream media
set this up for a failure they were
rooting it reading for it to fail
because they don't want anything trumped
us to succeed he had it okay the opening
statement okay you know and we in sync
with that tweet that he made from Air
Force One it was okay but then to go
into Hillary and the server and the
world what are you talking about please
stop it you know and I felt very badly
for for him it's not a you know totally
unforced there are I feel badly for him
I would totally if I were a feel badly
for I feel badly because he worked hard
at it and he wants that he wants the
best I really believe he's what you
understand what he wants out of North
Korea you understand what he wants out
of the NATO summit I guess I don't
understand a what he wants here and
and be why he's so deferential to a
horrible person 90% of the world's
nuclear weapons are held by these two
guys these they hope they had the
trigger to 90 percent of the nukes on
earth
I submit that Fiat friends with Putin
and having a relationship with Putin
where you can pick up throat and talk to
Putin is valuable to the United States
and I furthest a bit that Muller should
take Putin up on this deal he should
send his agents to Moscow when they
question those dirty dozen let them what
are we afraid of that the Muellers guys
are gonna like blurt out some state
secret that you know some spook and the
corner is gonna write down I'm answer a
dick and let they it's a good idea it's
a good idea let them let him talk to
these guys let let our our prosecutors
watch the Russia prosecutors ask these
dudes questions how could their heard
what one in exchange what Putin said in
the press conferences he wanted to be
able to question Bill Browder an
American citizen and the lawyer who was
defending the Magnitsky Act that's one
reason I could see why not to do it but
let's get Jesse in here here's what I
would have said if I was the president I
would have said Russia meddled and I
trust our agencies assessment of it and
this happened under Obama and no votes
were changed i confronted vladimir putin
about this he denied it it is what it is
we're trying to move past it now we've
put that behind us and were gonna try to
work together towards peace I know why
he didn't do it because he doesn't want
to say anything that's gonna undermine
his amazing victory over Hillary Clinton
and you can't get past that and that's
very important to him
also he can't understand why Russia
would want Hillary as president because
he would be so much tougher and it has
been more tough I think he has to say
that because he one of the good
relations exactly and but I don't think
Trump can understand that because he
believes he's very tough as Greg
mentioned and then thirdly I don't think
he fully the president trusts our
intelligence agencies for a number of
reasons he was very critical during the
primary about the WMD Fiasco when all
the intelligence agencies said Iraq Adam
they didn't and we lost a lot of blood
and treasure
in that desert and now he's got the form
of DNI director for us CIA director
former FBI director all kind of scheming
against him during his candidacy and
then afterwards throwing spies in there
listening to phone calls and then
actively undermining him during the
early stages of his presidency so that's
where he is now exactly dan coates is
not talking about Dan Coates I'm talking
about clapper Moeller what's up he
contradicted what Dan Coates said Dan
kono and he's gonna have plenty of
chance to clean that up on Hannity and
on Tucker but to your point he said
whatever he said and he's going to get
criticized no matter what if he goes in
and he tries to mend fences with Putin
they're calling him a traitor if he goes
in and starts an arms race with Putin
he's a warm-up exact he's gonna get
criticized no matter what and if you
think about some of the things that
Putin wanted before the summit he didn't
get any of those things he wanted troops
out of Syria he wanted us to stop
sending heavy weapons to Ukraine he
wants the Crimea annexation to be
recognized he wants sanctions lifted he
wants visas unfrozen he didn't get any
of that if the media is acting like
Trump gave Alaska back to Russia nothing
even comes close to that we have
discussed that could I answer the
question that you brought it was like
what does he want out of this I do think
as president the United States he's
seeking to reduce the adversarial turf
around the globe while substantially
increasing our military strength so
basically what he's done he said I've
got the sticks gotten bigger
here are the carrots you if you want
these carrots you can have them and
it'll be a really great experience but
if you don't want them this is the stick
this is exactly what he did with north
North Carolina North Korea what I guess
what makes me laugh is that peace seems
to be breaking out all over and and a
lot of people who normally would be for
that or against it and it's like the
champions of dialogue are getting
crushed by the dialogue or in chief he's
actually better at this if you again
he's the he's the good cop with his
words he's the bad cop with his deeds
you've got sanctions expulsion and
you've got the build up of this amazing
military you know what I mean he does
have faults and he does have flaws but
so far it seems to be working
he's gonna be on the words the DT the
deeds Geraldo I listen I've no no beef
that what you the substance of your
remarks but I know the president well
enough to know that he's going to be
smarting on that flight home gonna be
really angry he's gonna damn it he's
good he's gonna what was a success in
his own mind when he left that podium
right is gonna turn to ashes now
everybody making fun of them you know
and he doesn't take that criticism but
what is the alternative to dialog when
all these people are angry it's like
would you want us to nuke I kill Moscow
I thought what you want neutrality but
you know you know this Dana from the
inside out every president wants to thaw
Vladimir Putin's icy heart they want
peace in the Middle East and they want
some resolution in North Korea this
president has tried to do all three in
his first year hard if I don't I don't
know if that's possible with with Putin
the peace is just a complete and total
liar and he wants to reconstitute the
Soviet Union and he is going to be he's
been in power a lot longer than
president Trump will be in if Trump gets
re-elected he's there eight years
President Putin will still be there
years later so this is routine year so
it's a blip on the radar for President
Putin and I don't think that Putin is
not going to change and he has no
incentive to but you can compete you
could have those competing thoughts in
your head at the same time you don't
need that one thought like the Putin
cannot be trusted that's one thought the
other one is we have to deal with them
that's another thought you can have both
those thoughts in your head the problem
is the media makes it though if you if
you meet with Putin clearly you trust
him or you're in bed with them you're
calling them treasonous treasonous those
beans about to Brennan did I think
Brennan's hyperbole is a little beyond
the scope of acceptability thank you